tout le monde s'accorde à dire que les
entreprises doivent avoir une politique
qui serait davantage respectueuses de
l'environnement et que c'est une justice
qu'on doit aux générations futures
simplement ce qui est de l'ordre du
réglementaire ou du droit économique n'a
rien à voir avec la responsabilité
pénale des entreprises toutes leurs
dirigeants et à force de vouloir à tout
prix instaurer des peines de prison
notamment sur des choses qui relèvent
vraiment davantage de la politique
pénale on risque de jouer au chat et à
la souris avec des entrepreneurs qui
finalement d'abord n'auront aucune
lisibilité parce qu'il ya aussi un flou
est ce important qui règne sur les
conditions de cet éco side
j'ai vu que là notamment la question de
l'intentionnalité du délit d' écocide
tel qu'il est actuellement discutée dans
la proposition du gouvernement fait
débat et toute cette insécurité
juridique risque en fait simplement
d'éloigner les entreprises les moins
respectueuses de l'environnement du
territoire français et au lieu de créer
des usines en france sont les faire
ailleurs tout en causant les mêmes
dégâts sur l'environnement
en fait il ne faut pas voir qu'une
écocide comme l'unique réponse au
problème de la responsabilité les
entreprises évidemment il faut renforcer
les seuils en matière justement
d'autorisation administrative pour qu'on
n'est tout simplement pas à saisir le
juge
ensuite on les destructions provoquées à
l'environnement dans la définition du
crime d'écosystèmes avait proposé par la
convention citoyenne pour le climat est
tel que nous la défendons en tant
qu'association je rappelle que je suis
président d'une association qui
s'appelle widely gueule nous défendons
une décorrélation entre le droit
administratif et le droit pénal puisque
aujourd'hui malheureusement ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il y à des actions qui
sont commises par les entreprises qui
sont absolument toléré par le droit
administratif qui tombe légal d'un point
de vue administratif et y pour autant
constitue aux yeux de la société
actuellement des dérives et des dommages
qui sont irréparables et qui ne sont
plus tolérables
aujourd'hui nous demandons donc une
décorrélation entre ce genre de
situations qui sont tolérées par le
droit administratif et libérer les mains
du juge pénal on pouvoir aller
rechercher la responsabilité des
entreprises qui se comporte de cette
manière il ya d'autres intérêts dans
notre société les intérêts en matière de
santé publique des intérêts en matière
de sécurité des populations
les intérêts en matière de protection de
l'environnement qui eux passent après
les autres intérêts et aujourd'hui ce
n'est plus tolérable sur la définition
qui est proposée par le gouvernement du
délit d costing malheureusement cela ne
va rien changer puisque la définition
telle qu'elle est rédigé actuellement
non seulement elle s'attaque uniquement
aux atteintes à l'environnement qui sont
volontaires or prouver l'intention d'une
entreprise de polluer l'environnement
c'est comme une preuve diabolique ça
n'existe pas c'est très difficile alors
que en l'occurrence nous demandons que
les la négligence et les atteintes aux
règles de sécurité soient sanctionnées
et donc on voit qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement avec la rédaction de
itélé actuelle elle va aller nulle part
elle nous permettra pas de renforcer les
mesures en matière de protection de
l'environnement et c'est ça qui est très
dommage
j'ai l'impression qu'il ya une volonté
d'enfumage de la part du gouvernement
qui crée des mesurettes tout en
employant des grands mots pour donner
l'impression de prendre des mesures
strictes
sauf que ça va rajouter une
complexification du droit qui sera pour
le coup très préjudiciables aux
entreprises qui déjà ont à faire un
corpus de normes et de règlement qui est
stratosphérique
on est quasiment les tenants du record
mondial en termes de normes et de
réglementations juridiques en france et
ça va complexifier encore davantage la
vie économique de ces entreprises pour
finalement un impact sur l'environnement
très limité et je crois aussi
on en revient à la question
philosophique qu'on commence à instaurer
l'idée que la nature aurait des droits
par elle même et pas simplement les
êtres humains qui y vivent qui ont droit
à vivre dans un environnement préservé
et que la nature deviendra une entité
métaphysiques dont il faudrait prendre
soin même titre qu'un être humain et ça
je crois que c'est très dangereux parce
que ça va dégrader progressivement la
représentation philosophiques
métaphysiques conseil de l'environnement
ça va de pair avec d'autres formes
extremis de l'écologie que son
la préservation des animaux qui tend à
une dérive antispécistes que sont la
protection des océans comme s'il avait
une personnalité morale ou juridique et
ça je crois que c'est dangereux
ce qui est un peu terrible finalement
dans cette situation c'est que il ya eu
un travail de fait de la part des
associations et la convention citoyenne
paul ii climat le gouvernement n'ont pas
tenu coût est aujourd'hui le signal que
qui est envoyée c'est que ce sont les
entreprises qui finalement vienne
raboter encore une fois le texte initial
alors que ce qui était promis c'était un
passage sans filtre devant le parlement
et aujourd'hui on voit bien que non
seulement le gouvernement est revenu sur
son engagement initial en plus les
grandes associations patronales réécrire
le texte
et au final on va avoir un texte
finalement très léger et très fin qui
n'aura pas vraiment de conséquences
ou en tout cas pas celle qui était à la
hauteur des espoirs des citoyens